Les nouvelles chaines de Golden Moustache
Salut à tous mes petits abonnés aujourd’hui
pour ma morning routine, on va prendre du
fond de teint make up forever,
de la poudre
Mac,
le contouring de chez Gemey Maybeline.
Bonjour à tous les abonnés je vais utiliser…
un…
...un feutre.
Heu là ça ne marche plus très bien parce
que je l’avais quand même bien utilisé
en seconde, alors…
Yo, tout le monde, c’est Squeezie.
Je suis très heureux d’ouvrir cette nouvelle
chaîne Golden Moustache.
On va kiffer.
Yo, tout le monde, c’est Squeezie.
Je suis très heureux d’ouvrir cette nouvelle
chaîne Golden Moustache
Bonjour à tous ! Je viens de recevoir ma
Playstation, on va l’ouvrir
et la découvrir ensemble.
Excitation
Alors aujourd’hui on parle du dernier Star
Wars… Alors pourquoi un plan séquence sur
le combat final entre Voldemort et John Skywalker
? C’est justifié par la présence du dragon
qui…
Ok stop merci.
En fait t’as juste pas vu le film ?
Non, non je l’ai pas vu !
Alors pour commencer on a le F ! Et…
Je vous propose un monde plus solidaire, un
monde où le chômage n’existe plus.
Un monde où la confiance, le travail, la
famille sont des valeurs remises au centre
de la société.
Pfff ouais, je vous propose surtout de voter
pour moi, parce que là je vous mets une carotte
mais dans le fond, je m’en bats vraiment
les couilles.
Coucou les amis, alors en fait, à la fin
de la saison 5 de Game of Thrones, Jon
Toi, t’es à la caf, t’es une merde, moi
j’ai largement assez de thunes !
Comme Francis Lalanne m’a nommé, je vais
le faire.
Ok, Francis Huster, Francis Cabrel, c’est
à vous les gars.
Je suis mort
La fécondation, c’est le stade de la reproduction
sexuée consistant en une union des gamètes
mâle et femelle en une cellule unique nommée
zygote.
Faut… heu… voilà quoi hein
Mais lâchez moi !
Lâchez moi, je me le fais
Tu crois que j'ai peur de lui ou quoi ?!
Je vais me le faire !
Salut à tous, bienvenue sur Golden Gaming
! Aujourd’hui, on va faire un speed run
sur Super Mario 3, premier monde, un grand
classique.
Ouais mais c'est aussi, là, c’est mal foutu le truc aussi.
Je crois qu’il y a un petit souci Golden
Moustache
ce concept, je l’ai déjà.
Non mais attends, je suis sûr qu’il y en
a un pas loin…
Oh ! Un Julfenouil !
Mais c’est dans le titre putain, c’est
dans le titre !!
Non, vraiment pas non.
NON putain !
MOVIES
Je suis très heureux
Non mais arrêtez de vous foutre de ma gueule,
je sais bien qu’il n’y en a pas !
Je m’en bas les reins !
Abonne-toi !
Désabonne toi!
Salope